word has spread that Chef Ramsey is in
town hello and the restaurant that is
normally not very busy right this way is
booked for you sir a chicken cine okay
tonight Chef Ramsey will continue to
examine the dysfunctional workings of
this restaurant uh jeez what's all this
[__] here
for hello shf people does anyone
actually sit down here they do yes they
do and when you uh when they sit on this
do you not think this looks
Dr I don't have a better one you don't
have a better one how about
nothing what is
that wow Merry
Christmas what is this I mean
honestly when was this cleaned not for a
long time sure you are in charge of
front of the house right fine I am oh my
god there you go that's your card The
Joker how fitting is
that how old is this chair 20 years 20
years 20 years what kind of message does
it send when you have this in the middle
of the dying room I mean that does look
like it's gone past his cell by day
right yes when was the last time it was
cleaned I would say a couple years ago
oh my God have you seen down there yes
and that's acceptable for you that's not
clean sir no oh my God you are kidding
me oh no what was that looks like a comb
looks like a comb oh come on Randy do
you think this is funny in front of the
customers not at all the crumbs in the
[__] down there you're not putting it
back there are you no I'll take it out
there get it the [__] out
man wash my [__]
hands I wasn't totally flabbergasted the
trash fell out of some somebody's pocket
somebody didn't see it was there you
know I don't feel that bad about that W
covering in
dust oh my God what a mess it's like rat
dropping
everywhere
get this is shocking you keep your dirty
shoes under the bonquet they are not
mine did the customer eye these holes in
the tole dirty crusty shoes oh I'm going
to wash my hands
again
man okay onion rings do we fix those or
are they already out what's that it's
from the steam table it's like a river
running through here God look at the
state of this stove how old is that
stove 33 years old wow I mean I know the
restaurant's cool the old neighborhood
but the kitchen's an old dilapidated
neighborhood yeah what is that is that
your wow you are kidding me he sticks it
in the prime rib and he sticks it back
in
there what's that spr canned coating so
it doesn't stick a canned coating yes
wow my mother's definitely lost her high
standards over the last 15 20 years here
you go
Brandy I know she cares for this place
but the passion and the fire that I've
seen in her before is no longer there
hey fet fillet lamb chops God damn it I
probably burned them son of a
[__] okay here we go here's your
sausage pizza holy CRA is that
ridiculous it's like the pizza there at
Denver yeah [__] okay I'll let you take
that in thank
you
man oh my
God dripping in green
they're oil grease coming out of
[Music]
that they oil in there look at the
grease that's
gross he said it's too greasy just
exactly what I I feel oh shut up I don't
want to
[Music]
hear honestly the best pizza in Denver I
mean does that look like the best pizza
trust me I can tell you it doesn't taste
good sisa the dough is so thick why I
mean it's just like a loaf of bread it's
like a baguette in there mhm that's our
thin crust that's the thin crust mhm
stop wow seriously yeah a lot of people
get upset with me for that when they ask
for the thin crust and I bring them the
thin crust wow did you touch that that
is raw oh wow it is raw pastry my God
what a mess D I'm done all righty that
Dreadful okay I'll let him know messy
that is definitely not the best pizza in
Denver let's getting that right hey Pete
he wanted me to show you the dough
what's wrong with that pizza he said the
pizza was doughy on the inside and
greasy it is doughy look really I agree
with him too are you kidding me I don't
know what the chef is talking about and
a lot of people love it I do I eat it
don't you guys throw this away leave it
I'm going are you kidding me what that's
disgusting I'm hungry
I think seph Ramon's problem is that he
hasn't tasted a classic Pizza before
damn is good he's tasted all this fancy
stuff you
know cherl want you to put your black
Chef coat on next fil so I'm sort of
looking forward to a really nice classic
piece of meat show you where it is strip
down baby I'm not looking get
excited we have a flaming flaming on
that I serve table side people just
love the chef's dream
fion something simple something
classic and something that's not
normally served on a
[Music]
troll what the
[__] what is that thing these are roof
tile reading it from the tile yeah I'm
going to finish it it's still cooking
you'll love this yeah I love
this what's that in there this is butter
and garlic oh garlic butter mhm they go
top and so the tsunami is the garlic
butter running down the drain pipe right
watch out all stuffing the
end wow you enjoy that thank you very
much quite
welcome
wow
[Music]
me that's the toughest the most
cheeriest filion I've ever tasted in my
entire life think so chewy is have meat
so tough me to yeah no I I I finished
take this out of your way thank
you chef tramps he hated the food he
hated the decor and I can't understand
why by SE
skullets avocado egg
rolls chrisy sh
wons wow Mexican Asian Indian it sounds
like a fusion
confusion how are you Hi how are you
nice to see you my name is Amy Amy nice
to see you nice to meet you likewise I
love that smile thank you what's the
style of food here what is it is it
classic American or no I think it's a
classic Mexican with American twist
twist or a twisted Chef or a is there a
misprint on there or is that me grilled
Caesar salad no really the lce is
grilled H tap it on the grill you never
heard of that no it hasn't hit London
yet okay I'll start off with that the
grilled teesar no chicken just just you
know what throw the chicken in there why
not throw the chicken in there I'll go
for the um um hello Hi how are you
before you steal my knife and for can
you say hello oh yeah my name is Kevin
Kevin good to see you bud can I help you
yeah we're thrilled to have you here I
hope you can make some sense out of this
[__] yeah
Kevin I need
[Music]
you can you excuse me for a second
please you you're busy
yeah I thought he was a thief that was
random very random yeah I don't know
what he what does Kevin do he's a
bartender he's a bartender yeah so he
really shouldn't even be over here right
now I I don't bartender that just pops
up and clear tabl I don't know what he's
doing
multitasking okay where were we I'll go
for the flash fried
oysters um I'll go for the grilled
salmon and as it's ready just send it
thank you D you're
welcome coming in Chef I'm ringing in
his orders okay okay so be prepared to
me it's Chef R who's just another
customer I mean as long as he likes my
food we're going to get along just fine
the
salad good to go walking out I think
he's going to love the salad wa to grow
lettuce I mean can't go wrong grilled
salad come
on it is grilled you're still amazed I'm
shocked I've never thought about it but
it's true like wait why are we grilling
lettuce sorry for interrupting just two
seconds but this is a first for me a
grilled Caesar
salad they
actually grilled the
lettuce um could you just show a hand if
anyone else has ever had a grilled Cesar
salad before anybody here ladies
no sorry for interrupting
sorry oh
jeez I always get nervous when a chef
serves me the butt of the lettuce when
you've got the butt of the lettuce on
you can never clean the lettuce properly
and unfortunately it's not very nice
inside dry chicken the salad looks
hideous why is it so spicy take it
everything is spicy Everything Jesus
thanks thrilled Caesar salad let's order
okay got to go for the stuffed uh banana
peppers um I've got to try that Italian
stuff Fila okay how do you like it done
medium rare please okay um careta our
signature sauce and who came up with
that idea Dino Dino mhm it came to him
in a dream really
mhm our claim to fame came a Dream from
someone who knows nothing about food or
how to prepare it flipping act
okay um got to go for the chicken
caretta cuz that's the sauce that was
dreamt of one night in his dream
absolutely than very much
absolutely and it begins don't sweat the
chef do what you guys normally
[Music]
do what is that olive oil yeah but it
doesn't taste like olive oil you mind by
a little taste it's very
watery tastes like frying oil it does
excuse me so is Tina nearby absolutely
please thank you wow that's Dreadful
Tina shoves Ramsey's asking for you at
43 uh no Tina has been such a hands-off
manager for so many years now that she's
become so blaz yes sir what is that
olive oil there is that canol oil no
it's pom is that the is that what you're
serving there it's that mix look at
that jeez it smells off you smell that
what's in there I don't know when was
the last time they were
cleaned I don't know you're the front of
house just what a mess it's a bathroom
nearby I can screen wash my hands to the
right [__] what happened there what's
that ter oh my God are they done every
day probably couple weeks ago is that a
fake TM with Su like it's that's a real
tumor suit oh come on no that's so
that's just sat there from fresh and you
said 2 weeks no probably 3 weeks ago
that is longer than 3
weeks this stinks I'm sorry my God Sam
yes how long have these desserts been
sat here a couple months a couple couple
months couple of months you just only Me
3 weeks no I would say under a month was
a couple months do they stay out all
night yeah that is a [__] health
hazard oh my God [__] my boots I can't I
can't do
this there Chef right here
[Music]
okay here's our stuffed filet this is
the stuffed filet yes oh excellent thank
you D you're
welcome
wow what a mess I asked for Mid rare but
it's
real it's almost like you got to stick
your knife in it to to kill it I mean
the thing's still [__]
moving um Sam I'm trying to cut into
that I also some mid rare but it's like
raw it's a little raw is that steak
Frozen probably could you just chat with
the chef
please was that steak Frozen he wants to
know I don't was this Frozen yeah yeah
that one okay well he said it's raw I
don't know if I should laugh or cry
which one what's that in there that's CH
gold excellent who made that the chef
under the supervision of me wow and are
you always in the kitchen or I I do
everything just to make sure everything
runs okay right lose the head chef that
would be me young man and first name is
Daniel the menu was designed
by are you do the menu
yes good to meet you all can't wait to
taste
it thank you and here the lunch menu
thank you very much and your server will
be right with you thank you wow bizarre
menu it's like something out of an
office fining cabinet hi there how you
doing well thank you how are you I'm
very well thank you I'm Matthew great
accent thank you how long you been here
what almost 2 years I met Dr Morris Dr
Morris can be a little overbearing
sometimes it's just the way she wants
everything to be perfect why do we have
to call a doctor uh that's just she's Dr
Morris but even in a restaurant yes the
doctor's office is next door what
literally next door literally next door
what a headache oh believe me I think
she's really taking on too much I
personally think she's slowly but surely
running herself into an early grave we
have salad that needs to take out now it
doesn't matter it needs to be
we're taking it right now so I'll go for
the Jamaican patties one veg and one
beef mhm got to got to got to have the
hot flashes okay so which is your jerk
chicken right that's our sign dish yes
looks like you're having some hot
flushes you right yeah it's hot in here
is it yeah plus it's wearing this get up
as well I mean I feel like I'm at
funeral sometimes when I come to work
wow wow wow wow wow wow famous Joe
chicken Marin in secret joke sauce
what's the secret behind her uh the
owner of the restaurant makes the sauce
really the owner pretty much does
everything I'm not even sure the cooks
even make the sauce seriously the chef
doesn't even know the secret behind the
sauce
no uh la la I just spotted mind you $20
that can't be right well it must be a
phenomenal oxtail at $20 yeah it's good
let's have that as well okay excellent
now stop sweating and
relax okay I see what we got guys two J
bacon patties uh one beef one veggie
jerk chicken and one tail okay let's go
you guys we need to get the Jamaican
patties first please yes Dr moris
everything's soulless it's it's lacking
charm and it's like eating inside of a
an office
block not good tell them let's go
they're going they can't go any faster
do you have the jerk sauce sing out
right
now Dan yes Dr Morris we need the next
plate are you working on this yes Dr
Morris okay pleas Patty yep with a
little little bit of more jerk SAU there
and this is the veggie
patty okay I'll leave you to enjoy those
thank
you absolutely gross that sauce is
[Music]
Dreadful p is raw soggy pile of dough
they would [__] kidnap me if I serve
that in Jamaica right now how are the
petties and sauce is Dreadful I don't
like it myself it's like a glue the sad
news about the Pate past is undercooked
it's hideous hideous let me get rid of
these for you and this one is the jerk
chicken hot flashes is that the same
sauce yes take that way please D take
this way got it thank you look at my
rice it looks like a silicon impact
perfectly
formed guys do not put any more jerk
sauce on his plate he hates
it oo nasty not an ounce of seasoning
there cold how's our signature a dish
Bland as
[__] cold chicken disgusting over cooked
rice and when was that chicken cooked I
couldn't tell to be honest with you go
and ask doctor this is dry as hell we it
thank
you how are you I'm great nice to see
you and first name is gaale I'm the
manager okay great how long have you
been here 20 years 20 years here 20
years wow wow wow what's that
monstrosity in the middle there that's
our dessert case this what your dessert
case is it problem with the kitchen or
does it always stay here it's been here
for 20 years that I know of so it came
when you came wow what is this that's
our dessert TR holy crap did someone
drop it they could have how long has
that brick been sat there that's our
homemade bread pudding that's been there
I think longer than youve been
here well they yeah you're right yeah
okay Chef Ramsay's right about the
dessert case I think it should be out of
here right where was you like to sit
here yes sir I've been trying to get it
out ever since I've been here can you
hear the noise of that thing in the
motor who wants to come out to a
restaurant and sit next to a fridge
constant Buzz um is Andre around would
you like to see yes please yeah okay
thank you good to see you likewise good
to see you
too dessert fridge is a
disaster Andre yes Chef Ramsey would
like to see you yeah color's
ghastly
G how are you how are you all right yeah
good to see you again my daugh how are
you I'm s good to see you nightwise
she's going to take care of
you Gordon coming here was pretty much
my idea you're going to look at the menu
for a minute absolutely definitely I'll
be right back thank you s because it's
really become a big pointing finger
match of it's so and so's fault oh it's
so and so's fault but nobody's taking
responsibility for the problem I'm back
you have any questions for right now um
what key would you recommend I prefer
the line that's something we're known
for let's do the line the line and then
I'll start with free salad and then the
seaa crepe not a problem thank
you guys this table that's coming in
right now is for
Gordon
crepe I'll take the leaf FR salad to him
Chef gry would like the food because all
my food is
good how much dressing would you like
the usual amount thanks do about 3/4 a
start
[Music]
and inside the salad we've got inside
the salad is the Roma the um the walnuts
and you've got your blue cheese as well
and that's one portion it's massive
salads are large and it's usually good
as an entree thank
[Music]
you
wow it's bland the vinegar dressing is
[Music]
so the um vinegar dress dressing is so
strong just overpowering are you through
with the Sal yeah I am yeah that's so
acidic yep I already know did you
mention to the chef yeah no one listens
to me you knew it was wrong you told
them but no one's listening to you sorry
my life but why is that Martin doesn't
listen to me and he has an issue taking
anything from a female is this
chauvinistic stance yes some of it
that's absurd I understand that
disgusting I'll let him know thank you I
am embarrassed by the
I just think that it can all be improved
immensely Martin your vinegret is too
vinegary
okay you know what is wrong with it
because uh we've been running this food
for many years Martine you heard me
right I'm just letting you guys know
what he's saying
okay thank you this is going to be the
seafood grape I'm going to set that in
front of you here it looks like a pie
basically they take the dish they line
it with the with the Crepes they fill it
with the items full hold it back and
then they bake it they're not like your
typical French crepe but why would you
call it a crepe if it's not really a
crepe have you ever seen a kitchen like
this before this place is littered with
crap what's that there CO2 for the beer
look at those
shelves I mean that's Grime that's like
14 years of grime
there Chef Ramsey was that oh there's
dust here there's this is just like it's
not that
bad what what's in here d i vegetables
that's the vegetables what's this at the
bottom uh that's supposed to be eggplant
eggplant Parmesan when were they cooked
last Thursday last Thursday God
Almighty look at
that oh feel that tomato sauce you I
feel it I know it's we just made it
today made it today so what's it doing
in the
fridge hold that I know it's hot hold it
what does hot things do that are sealed
that goes inside a cold
fridge the sauce goes
sour I didn't know that you didn't know
that can I suggest you spend 5 minutes
sorting out your first before you start
cooking yeah
okay I should have known better he's
right but he's just a pain in the ass
about it Darren let me go through it
real quick yeah trash thank you with the
rotten vegetables thrown away I need to
order wings please and the orders
pouring in Jim and Jeff get back to
cooking Dane order green beans please
got it and begin to send food out of the
kitchen make sure they say a prayer
before they start eating that hey the
chicken I can't eat that but the diners
are less than impressed so
disgusting okay they sent this back they
didn't like it they said that they can't
eat
it what was this it looks like a pile of
mush and a pile of
mush big pile of
mush is anyone tasting anything
seasoning
tasting every time a dish came back it
was like losing a customer and uh it
hurts what was wrong with it it's too
flowery and not enough
sauce it makes me feel like a loser I do
really feel like a loser right
now
Jeff okay I'm just
frustrated come on huh I'm I'm working
on it just s get some fresh air
go I got this Budd what's the m just was
a
failure just you can't give up like that
I'm not trying to just it's not going
right I need to see what I've got to
work with before I can start looking at
any form of change you have to bounce
back I'm working on it I really Jeff
you've got to okay come on
okay let's go come on fight back let's
go come on the food is below
standard darl has some words of his own
you know chef says everything is [__]
it's embarrassing there's nothing good
about the menu you know I don't buy that
[__] I will never believe the food is
[__] you're not going to Comm I've been
eating this food all my life Chef Ramsey
doesn't under war on food that's it I
you cut all the food down you want you
can't break
[Music]
me it's an hour before dinner service
and Chef Ramsey hopes a private meeting
with the Two Chefs Emil and Jason can
shed some light on the restaurant's main
issues
okay so I don't get it some of the
things I encountered there today were
just awful
that can't be your wish to cook with
frozen ingredients we talk about it
every day and it just get swept on the
table I tell him the second he starts
cutting cost getting a cheaper product
you know it's going to taste like [__]
and trying to explain that to him you
know is like talking to this wall right
here and how long has it been going on
like that since the right round of time
he took over the only thing Daryl and
Ellen see is money and that's what
scares me their whole purpose is money
money money money money we feel like our
hands are so tied as far as ordering
goes everything goes the only other
option was to leave me and him both go
yes you know what do you do just walk
out the place I mean we got a lot of
personal memories in this place just to
walk out of it granted I I get that but
it doesn't stop you from having your
voice everybody here is just kind of
waiting for the place to belly up and go
find a new job somewhere else I'm here
to help put this freaking Place back on
the map yes sir you're absolutely right
we have only two options Chef Ramsey are
God and I don't think the second
comments happen anytime soon thanks for
the catchup thank you thank
you
[Music]
after gaining some insight from Jason
and Emil hey I need shrimp portions Chef
Ramsey is eager to see how this
restaurant functions in a dinner service
how does this
work uh
a when were these done um last night why
are they bagged he portioned them out to
order
[Music]
really what's the idea of putting
everything bags portion size portion
size I like to have everything in
quantitative perspective if I give too
much you get a happy customer here you
don't get a good customer they're happy
because they're getting three times what
they should be getting I'm getting
nothing I don't make money on that it's
food you know we're not cutting uh
piping
B hi welcome to zek's how many we have
in the party four it's jef Ramsey's
first time in Louisiana come right this
way please and not surprisingly zek's is
completely booked and tonight our with
lasagna lasagna
something I got a seafood ploted no
oyster sub shrimp I'm at the Expo
station I like to see all the food go
out a new potatoes down I uh make sure
every dish goes out like I want it to go
out can I run
anything
nope shrimp flatter can any of that go
I'm waiting on dishes to complete the
order it doesn't concern you that food
is just dying in the window well we're
pushing as hard as we can bloody
hell time for Expediting is one thing
standing here and saying nothing is
another wow Mark oh no can I even order
a chicken tenders CU they don't like
their chicken parm please all right yeah
I know 2 minutes there the
month's turkey chips TI chili waa come
on now that Chef Ramsey has observed the
pattern of fast food followed by fast
returns this pizza just got sent back he
decides to do an examination of the food
storage
this fridge is
Dreadful wow chicken breast oh my God
just dumped in there not even taken out
the bag that's how lazy they' become and
the whole fridge is not even chilled
it's warm there's not a decent
temperature on the floor here what is
that
unbelievable po belly in a carrier bag
on the
floor next to the PK belly you got
cooked chicken it's actually H side just
fested in there that's sat next to the
pork belly you got cooked chicken cooked
chicken raw pork Jesus
Christ what the [__] is that some form
of chili a I have salmon that was the
last one excuse
me you and you come
here look that is a what that's pork F
just hold that two seconds that's next
to this [__] wings and the top is
soaking wet because it's [__] full of
condensation and this who grabs that out
there and doesn't think about changing
the fold who could be that dirty chil
chil [__] around the outside look at the
mess of this place it's [__]
ridiculous someone [__] met up young
man you are running a business hot wings
next to [__] raw P you kill
everybody are these fides out here
behind the line the same way after a
service they're probably dirty show
me I didn't realize it was this bad and
that's a pretty awful
feel what the [__] what is that it's p
it was a pizza it was a
pizza what is that one how old is that
one then this one that one's got to go
will you seriously cook that for a
customer
can't and this one I mean look at
it count how many pieces are here please
hey and for me this is money now 25 25
what are you expecting a cruise ship
with 2,000 people coming in and then you
leave that setting there look you leave
that setting there you can't take that
out what's that oh no what is that
please that's a Hider is that tuna
that's a what a [__] a [__]
tuna that is a what oh [__]
me and when was this last cleaned at
don't don't don't don't don't don't you
dare tried to tell me that was done from
last night oh God no God no that I
missed wow what a
mess there's one thing you're going to
have to learn get cleaning Mark you've
got no idea on the hundreds of thousands
of dollars that you've pissed through
your
[Music]
hands there's a steady stream of
undercooked dishes coming back to the
kitchen he can you oven please no no no
Colleen this supposed to be medium oh my
god oh no come on what is this Rocky
could you put these steaks on just a
tiny bit more all right guys this is
just in the last 5 minutes I don't know
what's going on but you know can someone
get a grip please another medium refire
this this normal all these complaints
with temperatures on me mhm especially
on the steaks is that acceptable to
you
people hate our food so far so good this
evening and she turns to Blind deer
which frustrates us all you know why
does reishi walk around like
everything's just perfect and a big
smile on her face that's what she
believes it all is what's wrong dnie
what's wrong the raviol is cold wow wow
wow yeah the kitchen needs help Lots
everything tasting
good the gravy feels like I got the
bottom of the pot okay thanks for your
comments um I just want to let you know
at this table right here here they both
think that the gravy tastes like it came
out of the bottom of the pan they're
really unhappy about that should I just
go ahead and take that back to the
kitchen then yeah it's your restaurant
which table this table right here let's
deal with it now come on and my
apologies Madam if you're not happy with
it I'd rather you didn't eat it sauce
tastes like Li ref fire a fresh chicken
for the lady with no sauce sorry about
that we'll get that going for you you
taste the gravy I'm going to taste it
yeah
the gravy tastes really gritty to me
where is it now I see right here Jeff
can you pass me that gravy everyone's
complaining about gra why they think it
tastes like liver cuz it's really gritty
when was it made gravy was made last
week and Frozen last week and
[Music]
Frozen oh my
God it's sour all of you get any fate of
gravy T off the tables now off the
tables
[Music]
now oh my God look at that dry as
anything the meats cooked and Raw on the
same
shelf Rocky you got the ribs there
what's next to the ribs raw pork raw
pork get reishi please reishi rule
number one cross contamination explain
to Rishi never sh cook product next to a
raw product so just look at that what is
that there raw product raw pork what's
that there cooked ribs cooked ribs and
this here what is this guys oh my God
it's trout what is new trout old trout
just feel how sticky that is on top
that's the old trout and that there is
the fresh one underneath right no we
pull today now you pull
today what is
that bread pudding bread pudding bread
what oh my God Rocky come on when was
that cooked Saturday what day is it
today two days and what we didn't sell
on Saturday what do you think should
happen fastic oh my go stop ladies and
gentlemen I'm sorry and I'm am so
disappointed but whatever you're eating
now just stop
stop during dinner service owners Carol
and Terry were stunned by Gordon's
criticism of their head chef Pinto we
don't know our ass from a
home I'm so scared
he opened our eyes to a lot of things
throughout the restaurant that people
have been taking advantage of us so we
have to take a good hard look at
everything after a long difficult dinner
service the customers who have eaten are
not exactly thrilled chicken's a little
overdone okay so too soupy and the
chicken is overdone I didn't eat much of
my salad cuz I didn't really care for
the dressing and those who haven't been
served are not willing to wait we got
here 5 over s okay so hour 5 minutes
I'll 5 minutes done okay all right table
5 is going to walk out in 5 minutes but
is this the pace we move at is this the
fastest we go Pino has one speed and
that speed is [__] you how long has it
been almost 2 and 1/2 hours some of the
customers have given up completely on
Cafe 36 and are leaving without even
eating an appetizer it's just been a
long day I have to really take it all in
that
hurts after a rough night Gordon
confronts the staff overall honestly
pretty
disappointing both in the kitchen and
the dining room there's one thing in
here that I would change
instantly on the back of my experience
today and that's
you why you are the executive chef
you're supposed to be a leader a
motivator you are seriously seriously
leading this place into
bankruptcy because the big problem in
this restaurant Pinto is in the kitchen
fresh frozen slow Thor I think that
Pinto deserved every single solitary
second of that ass reman that he got
from Gordon if this was your restaurant
would you be freezing everything poring
it and then dropping in bowls of water
to defrost it to recook it yes or
no no I
wouldn't
embarrassing do you think I enjoyed it
standing there and listening to this you
know I'm a proud man get the message now
show me your
pride Chef cuz I'm [__] waiting and
unfortunately whether you like it or not
the two people behind you it's them
you're dragging down that's why I'm
pissed so cut the
[__] get ready for some changes
because Kathy 36 needs it
urgently